The first thing I'm going to do is get all of the x's on the left side of the
equation. So that means getting rid of them on the right. Since 2x is being
subtracted, we add, and then we have 5x plus 6 equals 12. Now, I need to move
things around, so that all of the constants are on the right side. Subtracting 6
gives us 5x equals 6. All we have to do is divide both sides by 5. And since I
ran out of room, I will write our final answer of, guess what, x equals 6 5ths.
So in the end, we get the same answer that we did using the first method of
starting out by dividing by 3. But as you can see, this takes a lot of your
steps. Now, if everything on the right side of the equation had been divisible
by three, then that method may have been a little bit easier. But in many cases,
using the distributive property is going to make our lives simpler.